[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mes chers collègues le
nettoyage ethnique du haut carabar et
ces dizaines de milliers de victimes ne
sont que le premier acte d'une tragédie
qui si les appels de la France sont pas
entendu en comportera deux autres la
destruction à l'instigation de la Russie
de la démocratie libérale arménienne et
la remise en cause de la souveraineté et
de l'intégrité territoriale d'une
Arménie prise en tenaille par les
adeptes du
panturquisme il faut agir je vous pose
madame trois questions pour agir
première question le gouvernement est-il
prêt à saisir à nouveau le Conseil de
sécurité sur les décisions propres
assurer la protection des minorités
arméniennes demeuré au carabach ainsi
qu'à protéger à garantir l'intégrité
territoriale et la souveraineté de la
République de l'Arménie la question des
sanctions doit être légitimement posé
deuxème question au-delà de l'aide
humanitaire d'urgence le gouvernement
n'estime-t-il pas nécessaire de mettre
en place au niveau de l'Union européenne
un véritable plan marshal de
réinstallation des réfugiés afin
d'offrir un avenir à ceux qui ont tout
perdu et de faire baisser en Arménie
même une tension susceptible d'emporter
la démocratie 3è question que
comptez-vous faire pour militairement
l'Arménie à se défendre entendez-vous
répondre rapidement à sa demande d'armes
l'Union européenne a jusqu'à présent
refuser à l'Arménie la facilité
européenne pour la paix ce refus peut-il
enfin être levé l'honneur de l'Europe
est engagé dans cette tragédie si nous
oublions heréan nous oublions ce que
nous sommes et ce que nous devons rester
assez d'indifférence assez de
complaisance assz de l'acheter l'Arménie
doit
[Applaudissements]
vivre merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup la parole est à
madame la Première
ministre madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Jean-Louis bourlange avant
toute chose mes pensées vont aux
arméniennes et aux
Arméniens au moment où je vous parle
plus de 100000 d'entre eux ont dû fuir
le haut carabach fuir leur terre et leur
foyer c'est la quasi-ttalité des
habitants de cette région c'est un
véritable exode massif et organisé
monsieur le Président bourlange comme
vous le soullignez cette situation est
d'une extrême gravité après 9 mois d'un
blocus illégal nous faisons face à une
offensive militaire de l'Azerbaïdjan en
violation du cesser le feu sous le
regard complice de la Russie qui a rompu
tous ses
engagements je le dis devant vous nous
condamnons fermement ces actions de
l'Azerbaïjan
très vite la France a pris ses
responsabilités aujourd'hui même la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères Catherine Colona est en
Arménie pour voir comment renforcer
notre coopération dans tous les domaines
et dire notre solidarité au peuple
arménien nous sommes mobilisés au plan
humanitaire notre aide a triplé pour
atteindre 12,5 millions d'euros depuis
le début de l'année une aide médicale
d'urgence est arrivée en Arménie ces
derniers jours et à ce soutien s'ajoute
les efforts des collectivités
territoriales et de la société civile
que je veux saluer en parallèle à cette
réponse à l'urgence humanitaire la
France est engagée pour réaffirmer son
soutien sans faille à la souveraineté et
à l'intégrité territoriale de l'Arménie
nous agissons au sein de l'Union
européenne l'Union intervient au plan
humanitaire et à activé le mécanisme de
protection civile européen nous sommes
engagés pour tirer toutes les
conséquences de cette offensive
militaire et pour bâtir un véritable
plan européen d'appui à une Arménie
indépendante souveraine et démocratique
nous continuons également à mobiliser le
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies et
a appelé l'ensemble de ses membres à
prendre leurs responsabilités une
mission de l'ONU est actuellement au
haut carabach pour évaluer les besoins
humanitaires monsieur le Président
bourlange la situation est grave
condamnons l'offensive de l'Azerbaïdjan
nous sommes solidaires du peuple
arménien et nous soutenons la
souveraineté de l'Arménie la position de
la France est claire et nous
continuerons à la défendre aucune paix
durable ne pourra être atteinte dans le
sud Caucase par la menace ou par la
force je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre